La inmigración es un tema candente en los
Estados Unidos.
Y un tema polarizarte.
Puedes estar a favor o estar en contra, pero
difícilmente vas a permaneces impasible.
O consideras que la inmigración es una oportunidad
o una amenaza.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
en los Estados Unidos existe otro tipo de
inmigración de la que no se habla tanta,
pero que supone que cada año un enorme flujo
de personas se trasladen de un territorio
a otro.
Estoy hablando de la inmigración ínter-estatal,
entre los propios estados que conforman los
Estados Unidos.
Y esto es algo que hace que haya estados ganadores
y estados perdedores.
Además, amigos, ahora con la última reforma
fiscal liderada por Donald Trump y el Partido
Republicano, todo apunta a que este tipo de
inmigración va a crecer.
Evidentemente, tal y como os podéis imaginar,
las personas suelen emigrar a los territorios
más prósperos.
Así que, hay unas cuantas preguntas que todos
podemos hacernos:
¿Qué está ocurriendo en los Estados Unidos?
¿Qué supone este tipo de inmigración?
¿Qué estados son los ganadores y cuáles
los perdedores?
¿Por qué lo son?
o… ¿Qué podemos esperar en el futuro?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(GANADORES Y PERDEDORES)
Cada año, miles y miles, millones de estadounidenses
hacen las maletas y se trasladan a vivir a
otro estado.
(Y, evidentemente, tal y como podéis suponer
hay estados que cada año tienen saldos positivos
de inmigración.
Es decir que, año tras año son más los
compatriotas que llegan que los que se marchan.
Y también, claro, lo contrario.
Algunos estados ven como cada año muchos
vecinos se mudan a otro estado, muchos más
de los que llegan.
Porque, amigos, lo que ocurre no es ni más
ni menos que los estados compiten entre sí.)
Claro, cada estado tiene sus propias características,
sus propias regulaciones, sus propios impuestos,
su política… y lógicamente esto hace que
algunos estados sean más prósperos que otros.
[Evidentemente la gente suele mudarse a lugares
más prósperas, a estado donde hay más
trabajo, mejores condiciones de vida o en
los que se están instalando más empresas.]
Bien, el caso es que cada año según los datos
IRS, del servicio de impuestos internos, la
agencia del gobierno federal que se encarga
de recaudar los impuestos, en 2016, el último
año con datos cerrados, se mudaron de estado
el 2,8% de los contribuyentes.
Según este dato [Y en Estados Unidos el Servicio
de Impuestos tiene probablemente los mejores
datos del país] la tasa de migración, de
movilidad interna en los Estados Unidos es
muy, pero que muy alta con otros países desarrollados]
Dicho esto, ¿Queréis saber cuales son los
estados con mayor déficit migratorio de estadounidenses?
Es decir, los estados donde cada año es mayor
la diferencia entre los estadounidenses que
se marchan y los que llegan.
Pues fijaos.
Sí, ya lo veis, Nueva York está a la cabeza
entre los estados menos atractivos para la
llegada de estadounidenses.
Tan solo en 2016 se marcharon en términos
netos, una vez descontadas las llegadas, más
de 150.000 norteamericanos.
Le siguen otros estados como Illinois, New
Jersey o California.
[¿California?
¿Alguien podría imaginarse que California,
la tierra de la tecnología, las playas kilométricas
y el buen tiempo estuviera en la lista.
Pues si ya lo veis.]
Y ahora la pregunta contraria, ¿Cuales son
los estados con mayor superávit migratorio
de estadounidenses?
Atentos.
Florida.
Con un saldo positivo de unos 200.000 estadounidenses,
Florida se ha convertido en la gran ganadora.
(Estos son los datos de 2016, pero si en vez
de tomar el último año con datos disponibles
tomamos un periodo de tiempo más amplio,
por ejemplo desde comienzo de los 90, el resultado
es prácticamente el mismo.
Nueva York, California e Illinois fueron los
estados que más estadounidenses perdieron,
mientras que Florida, Arizona y Texas fueron
los que mas norteamericanos ganaron.)
Y, ojo, porque esto es mucho más importante
de lo que parece a simple vista.
¿Recordáis el vídeo que hicimos hace poco
sobre la deuda oculta de los estados?
Pues, amigos, cada vez que un estado pierde
estadounidenses está perdiendo muchísima
riqueza.
Por ejemplo, los casi 200.000 norteamericanos
que se fueron a vivir a Florida, en términos
netos, en 2016 tuvieron ese año unos ingresos
de más de 17.000 millones de dólares.
Unos ingresos que a partir de ahora se producirán
en Florida, una parte de ellos se ahorrará
en las entidades financieras de este estado,
otra parte se gastará en tiendas, supermercados,
cines, restaurantes y gasolineras de Florida,
claro.
Y otra parte se invertirá en nuevas empresas
y nuevos negocios.
Todo esto supone más riqueza, más trabajo
y también más ingresos fiscales para este estado.
¿Veis lo importante que es?
Ya no parece tan poca cosa… ¿Verdad?
Ahora bien.
Visto todo esto, la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es, ¿Qué variables explican todo
este movimiento de personas?
Atentos.
(LA COMPETENCIA)
Son muchos los motivos que hacen que las personas
se muden de un lugar a otro: familia, trabajo,
clima oportunidades, universidades….
Sin embargo sí tomamos todos los datos de
forma agregada hay un par de factores que
destacan sobre otros.
Y uno de ellos son los impuestos.
(En 2016, casi 600 mil personas se mudaron
de los 25 estados con impuestos más altos
a los 25 estados con impuestos más bajos.
De hecho, de los 25 estados con impuestos
más altos, ni más ni menos que 24 tuvieron
emigración neta, es decir, vieron marchar
a más norteamericanos de los que vieron llegar.)
Y es que amigos, a pesar de lo que a veces
se dice la migración interior no está motivada
por el clima ni cosas parecidas.
Mientras que California sufre este déficit,
un estado como New Hampshire, pequeño, frío,
montañoso y con apenas una estrecha línea
de costa ha registrado superávit desde el
año 2000.
Y, ojo, porque los vecinos del estado de Joshua
Barlett, Rhode Island, Vermont o Massachusetts,
todos ellos con impuestos mucho más altos,
pierden norteamericanos cada año.
Y es que sí, New Hampshire es ni más ni
menos que el segundo estado con los impuestos
más bajos de los Estados Unidos.
¿Coincidencia?
Ni de lejos.
(Lo mismo ocurre en el medio oeste.
Mientras que Dakota del Sur en general registra
año tras año superávit migratorio de norteamericanos,
sus estados vecinos, con impuestos más altos,
Nebraska, Iowa y Minnesota han tenido déficits
migratorios 5 años seguidos.
Y también tenemos a Kentucky frente a Tennessee
o a California frente a Nevada, Texas o Washington.
Los estados con impuestos más altos pierden
y los estados con impuestos más bajos ganan.)
Aún más.
Un estudio elaborado por economistas del Departamento del Tesoro,
estimo que cuando New Jersey subió
en 2004 el impuesto estatal sobre la renta
en casi 2,5 puntos provocó el cambio de residencia
de más de 80 millonarios cada año.
Puede no parecer mucho, pero lo cierto es
que las rentas altas son las que proporcionalmente
más impuestos pagan.
Pero, un momento, junto a los impuestos están
también las regulaciones, por ejemplo y tal
vez, especialmente, las que afectan a la vivienda.
Veréis, una combinación de altos impuestos
a la propiedad y muchas regulaciones y limitaciones
para construir hacen que vivir en un estado
pueda ser muchísimo más caro que vivir en otro.
Es lo que ocurre precisamente en California.
("Los californianos hartos con los costes
de vivienda y los impuestos huyen del estado
en gran número". CNBC)
Amigos, el alquiler de un apartamento en Las
Vegas o en Phoenix cuesta de media menos de
la mitad de lo que cuesta un apartamento en
Los Ángeles o San Francisco.
Cuando vimos hace poco cómo surgió Silicon
Valley reparamos en que en toda esta zona
no había grandes edificios ¿lo recordáis?
Ahora podéis entender porque es tan caro.
Poca vivienda y mucha demanda, precio por
las nubes.
A muchas personas les compensa mudarse de
estado incluso aunque vayan a ganar menos.
Pero bien, esto ha sido así hasta ahora.
Y lo cierto es que podemos decir que el efecto
hasta el momento ha sido muy importante: los
estados que tienen superávit migratorio son
estados que también han sido capaces de crecer
más, en parte por tener políticas más atractivas
para las empresas, los emprendedores y, como
hemos visto, también los trabajadores.
Pero.. de aquí en adelante… todo apunta
a que va a ser mayor.
Todo gracias a Donald Trump y la reforma fiscal
del Partido Republicano.
Atentos.
(MÁS COMPETENCIA)
Tal vez una de las mejores cosas que ha hecho
Donald Trump.
La reforma fiscal de finales de 2017 no solo
supuso mejorar la fiscalidad a las empresas
sino también impulsar la competencia entre
los estados.
Me explico, hasta ahora el gobierno federal
subvencionaba una parte de los impuestos estatales.
Esto es porque eran deducibles, lo que pagabas
al estado te lo descontaban de los impuestos
que tenias que pagar al gobierno federal.
Era algo así como un incentivo a que los
estados subieran los impuestos.
Pues bien, la reforma fiscal ha limitado esta
situación de tal forma que el número de
hogares que podrán deducirse los impuestos
locales y estatales ha pasado de 42 millones
de hogares en 2017 a unos 17 millones en 2018.
Y además con importes de la deducción mucho
más pequeños.
Esto ha sido equivalente a una subida automática
de impuestos en los estados con impuestos
más altos.
Porque ahora sus contribuyentes tendrán
el íntegro el impuesto estatal y prácticamente
integro el impuesto federal.
(Por ejemplo, según cálculos de la Fundación
El Cato un contribuyente del estado de Nueva
York al que en 2017 le hubiera correspondido
un tipo del 33% en el impuesto de la renta
federal y 30.000$ en impuestos estatales y
locales podría haberse reducido los impuestos
federales en 10.000$.
Es decir, gracias a la deducción, los impuestos
estatales y locales le hubieran costado 20.000$
En cambio, ahora con la reforma tributaria
tendrá que pagar 30.000$ por los impuestos
estatales y locales, un 33% más.
Y eso se nota.)
Por tanto, amigos, ahora las diferencias entre
los estados con impuestos más altos y los
estados con impuestos más bajos serán mucho
mayores.
("Quizás si los estados con impuestos altos
no tuvieran esta muleta federal para apoyar
su enorme gasto, tendrían que bajar impuestos
para ser competitivos”.
Ronald Reagan )
De hecho, según ha publicado el Wall Street
Journal se está produciendo un auge en los
compradores adinerados que quieren comprar
inmuebles para establecer allí su residencia.
[En Florida no hay impuesto estatal sobre
la renta y sus impuestos sobre la propiedad
son también relativamente bajos]
En fin, ¿sabéis lo que significa todo esto?
Amigos, bienvenidos a una nueva era de competencia
entre los estados de los Estados Unidos.
Los gobiernos estatales van a tener ahora
mucha más presión para gestionar bien sus
presupuestos.
Y la evidencia nos dice que eso termina siendo
algo bueno para todos.
En fin, amigos, está es la rivalidad creciente
que entre bastidores empiezan a tener los
estados de los Estados Unidos.
Si te ha resultado interesante este vídeo
ayudamos dandole a like y compartiéndolo
con tus amigos.
Y por supuesto, si aun no lo has hecho no
dudes en suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.